- [Voiceover] The following
equation represents
the population growth of
bacteria in a petri dish.
So the population is a function of time.
Is equal to 350 times
two to the t power,
where P of t is the population after some
amount of time, t, measured in hours.
Which of the following best describes
the relationship between
the population of bacteria,
P, which is a function of t,
and the number of hours that have passed?
And the number of hours
is that lowercase t.
The relationship is linear
since the population has
350 more bacteria than the previous hour.
Well this is clearly, or we'll have to see
this is not a linear
relationship right over here.
What's gonna happen here?
When t equals zero, you can even see it
if you draw a little table here.
So if you say t and P of t.
When t is zero, well then the population,
two to the zero power is one,
one times 350 is...
The population's going to be 350.
When t is one, what's the population now?
Well, two the first
power is two times 350.
It's going to be 700.
When t is two, what's
going to be the population?
Well, two to the second power is four.
Four times 350 is going to be 1200.
Plus 200 is going to be 1400.
So what you see what's
happening after every hour
the population is doubling.
And you see that right over here,
'cause for every hour, you're gonna take
two to that power as you increment,
and then you're gonna
multiply that times 350.
So every hour, your
population is going to double.
After three hours, your
population's going to be 2800.
So this is definitely not
a linear relationship.
You definitely have much more than
just 350 more bacteria
than the previous hour,
so rule that out.
The relationship is linear.
No, not after you finish reading that.
The relationship is exponential.
Yep, that's what it looks like.
Since the population is 350 times larger
than the previous hour.
No, no, no.
It's not 350 times larger.
It's two times larger.
To get 350 times larger it would be 350
that you'd be raising to the exponent.
So we'll rule that one out.
So this better be our answer,
but let's make sure it makes sense.
The relationship is exponential
since the population
is two times larger.
The population is two times
larger than the previous hour.
That's exactly what we found.